do you believe that the Earth is a
sphere yes okay so you're not a flat
earther I am not so you are wrong the
Earth isn't a true sphere that's why I'm
wrong it's not a perfect sphere yes
because the Earth as it spins it kind of
bulges out like a ballerina doing a
twirl or a figure skater on the ice
you're less wrong if you say the Earth
is a sphere than if you say it's flat
but technically aren't you wrong well
this is a matter of degree Newton got us
the laws of the fundamental nature of
physics but it wasn't precisely right
Einstein later would come along and
correct Einstein had great respect for
noon and yet he said I have enough
Swagger to know I can be right where
Newton the great was wrong now Einstein
isn't the final word either and I think
that's a core element that only the
scientific method can validate who is
right but not necessarily only who is
right who is less wrong